good morning millennials welcome back to
morning toast hey
hey everyone hey
if you're watching on youtube and you
could probably even hear it already from
the podcast we have an unwell claudia on
our hands she is wearing an outfit that
she usually reserves for zoom toast well
honestly like
these my two favorite if you know
anything about me you know i have like a
bunch of pajamas these are my two
favorite sets the bottoms are from my
target halloween pajamas that are
year-round fun and my top is from my
skim's ex team usa i couldn't find the
pants to the skins or the top to the
target so here we have a target x skims
collab
those pants are crazy they have all
these different skeletons on them like
you knew in different colors if you knew
how comfortable these pants are they
must be to for you to walk around
looking like that
with plots that you've not been wearing
them i'm gonna get you a pair you know
okay wait i'm gonna get you a pair i
mean they're really really spooky like i
am [ __ ] spooked
from this halloween pants
boom
nothing could be scarier than your
pieces
oh god here we go
here we go honestly i'm in such bad
shape and i deserve it like i just
didn't stop didn't stop is this your
worst that you've ever been on the show
i don't think so
no
no
but it's not the best
clearly
but um you know how i knew when i was in
trouble
when when i
got home i was watching tv sex in the
city like oh that's that's how you know
and i literally like could not
see carrie like
my
eyes my eyes were going cross and i was
like i need to stay up and like eat a
piece of bread because i don't want to
puke you
yeah
i don't think there was an end to that
story i just cool yeah what's with you
all white girly um you know just really
excited that it's friday so looking
forward to the weekend can't even tell
you like i said i was so looking forward
to this week being over so just to be
here on this friday is is something
special you know i mean to be here with
like you in such bad shape is a shame
that we can't be like celebrating
together now cause like for me
she is to the freaking weekend i'll
she'll drink to that yeah
yeah i will and i just like
i've really been feeling lately like
alcohol is poison my jackie was like
just you sound like one of those people
like you knock on people's doors try to
get them join a cult you're like no no
i'm like campers again strong driving
like yeah
so give me your synopsis like look at
you you've been poisoned 100 my head is
[ __ ] killing me yeah but you did it
to yourself i mean there's a level of
alcohol that you can drink but without
being poisoned yeah no you just i have
to bypass it every time every time my
legs are killing me like
maybe it was like dancing like i feel
like i've worked out like i did barry's
boot camp like my legs are killing me
i just think i was like
walking around in my heels and that's a
workout that is
honestly it took every fiber of my being
to show up here today
yeah it was a close call we almost did
audio only but i had to talk about
the disgusting nature of what we were
subjected to last night we're here for
one reason only and that's justice for
trina j
f
t and that's the reason for us showing
up today um the stories actually are
pretty honestly we should have we should
have not shown up because we
were so disrespected yeah i cannot
believe what happened on love island
last night you didn't watch so i'll
explain to you all the traitors in the
house oh my god shut up because they
were the ones who voted the least
compatible couple okay because i was
thinking it was up to the house to vote
i was thinking that it was america how
did trina go from being a favorite no
it was the house voted
and they voted for trina and andre and i
i'm starting to feel like maybe the
producers
knew
come on at least you're on the other way
i was like what did i do wrong
talking to your mic sorry okay
you go you i'll just
i was starting to feel like the producer
saw the reddit threads saw the trina and
andre like that people were gonna game
the system that's not the outcome that
they wanted so they did this situation
where the islanders have to vote and
they like you know did their producery
thing where they had the islanders vote
off trina and andre because they didn't
want like a solo win
right or they're really trying to get
olivia olivia and corey to win who now
they are going to win
i don't know i voted for jeremy and
bailey i told you to vote for them also
okay i just want to say the love island
app sucks i was literally at the bar
last night trying to register i'm like
just letting me i had to register so
many times it was so difficult to vote i
didn't even end up getting to vote but i
was like in the bathroom i was like
everyone's like someone's being in the
door i'm like i'm trying to vote on love
island like please leave me alone i had
to refresh so many times but i finally
got my vote in and i saw on twitter like
the people who were for trina and andre
like literally didn't know what to do
with themselves were also like i guess
i'm voting for jeremy and bailey they're
the only couple they're like the least
worst of the couples because what's
wrong with charlie and elena will and
kyra i'll explain will and cara can't
win mm-hmm
olivia and corey can't win i'm sorry she
does deserve an emmy even though i don't
even think she's like doing a good job
of convincing us like they're just
insufferable so she deserves more of a
razzie
charlie and alana just haven't been
there long enough and that would just be
so crazy if they won they also have no
connection really like they have a
little connection just like trina and
andre did but if trina and andre were
going to get sent home then charlie and
alana don't get to win no i just feel
like all the people who are going to
vote for trina and andre are now split
like so no no one else is going to win
besides olivia
jeremy and bailey are the lesser of all
evils because one jeremy's been around
since day one so like he kind of he
deserves it he doesn't not deserve to
win him and bailey they've been cuddling
every night like they're really getting
intimate i think this is the closest
he's been with any girl yet and it's
showing growth on his part and like
we've just seen
so many sides of jeremy throughout yeah
and everybody has said he's like the
best person in the house he keeps
getting saved like let it be jeremy
yeah but the fact that he's been in the
bottom so many times is like america
doesn't like him it's a comeback story i
mean i'm here for it i think america is
really coming around to him i'll just
kind of feel robbed if like i tune into
this whole season to watch olivia and
cory win
no i will feel defrauded like i'm gonna
call my insurance agency and yeah there
was fraud because like since day one
i've just been waiting for each of them
to get sent home they had no connection
with anyone
and they just got by because they're
really popular yeah why are you looking
i'm just gonna say like the covering of
the mouth
jackie if only if you knew what i was
going through right now and the fact
that i'm here talking about these morons
okay i i tried to help you i'm trying to
help you i gave you a zofran did that
help it did oh my god
you have to have a prescription yeah but
i i have some stash if you want yeah no
i got to hit up by my local physician
zofran is magic it really is i've got
the magic
in me
oh by the way i've been told i'm wrong
the yellow part is supposed to be where
you hold
they both sound good you get two
different sounds girls come snatching
at me
everybody
wants some presto magic and then the guy
from pitchfork goes
and it's like a rap very cool yeah i
love that song ben platt's album came
out today i know i haven't had a chance
to listen to it i don't want to sound
stupid but what is it called reverie
i never heard that word before rev
referee
i never heard that word no it's like
i think it's reverie
it's sort of like a reverie like you
know oh it's like a reverse i don't know
like i don't know what it is but like i
think the word i'm gonna google the
definition and it's like when you just
take a reverie you know like a brain
revery
is
a state of being pleasantly lost in
one's thoughts a daydream oh my vanplant
is like so easy
reverie
it's a good question yeah no i've just
been like excited about it but i
couldn't talk about it because i don't
know how to say the word right i was
like embarrassed is there a song called
reverie on the album i i don't know i
haven't given it any of my time yeah
because i need to like sit down in a
dark room with my emotions and handle it
in order to listen to him honestly
sometimes it's too much it's i still
haven't watched this concert special
because it's just too much like
sometimes i don't want to feel so much
what's that one in case you don't live
forever stop donating it's really it was
kind of like unnecessary for him to make
a song that sad and like i'm disgusting
don't even talk about that song like is
a trigger first of all if you've ever
lost someone close to you like do not
listen to that song first of all it's
called in case you don't live forever no
you know what in case you talk about it
no no that song to me like if i was an
actress and i needed to cry on set i
would say play in case you don't live
forever and i would get the oscar it's
such a good song you guys yeah it's
crazy
i love you get up no no no no never wrap
your head around
that was good by the way yeah that was
you're giving us sticky shoes today my
sticky sticky shoe
i just feel like we should dive in
because honestly like um i don't know
how much time i have left here on this
earth like i agree on this couch for
sure i agree so without further ado do
to do where is brew i know i made some
big problems what the [ __ ] i ran an
errand this morning because we started a
little later and it's just too hot for
brew to be running errands with me
so brew by the way is turning one on
sunday i have like such a special
afternoon plan for him bru are we going
to ruby brews today
um
so i will try and bring him on monday
and by then he'll be one so he'll be
fully grown you know if i brought him if
i brought him today he'd still be a
puppy oh my god i cannot believe brew is
one can you believe he's the cutest
magnolia already won yeah she turned one
on may 23rd i feel like margaret didn't
make a big deal out of that one like she
should have like she
normally would i think she got like an
instagram post but her birthday's like
the day before or after michaela's so
it's like irrelevant irrelevant got to
see michaela that would make me feel
better um yeah that one
you may just pop over to her house
okay so let's get into everything so i
just needed to address bruce absence i
feel really
like a liar i feel like a liar
without further due to brew here are the
fast five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and i have literally nothing to say
because we've no sponsors today and
obviously that would make me sad because
i live a very lavish life and i need
money but if i had to read one of those
cards right now like i would not be able
to do it no you wouldn't it would be
unfair to the sponsor like no it would
be disgusting look at me who wants me
right now representing their brand
they're like healthy it looks like i was
hit by a truck yeah maybe health and
wellness yeah you could do a sponsorship
for trucks literally
hit me
okay you guys first story some crazy but
great news kelly clarkson's prenup has
been upheld in her divorce she
celebrates onset of the voice
a judge has fully upheld the stronger
singers prenuptial agreement with
brandon blackstock and their highly
contentious divorce tmz reported on
thursday the agreement reportedly
segregated all assets and income derived
from during her marriage to the former
entertainment manager blackstock had
been fighting the prenup in order to
split their accumulated properties
including the montana ranch where he now
resides as we said he like took to being
a rancher and is living in montana it's
easy to take yeah can it take to be a
rancher when your wife bought you a
ranch in kelly's house so now he has to
vacate the ranch right like you didn't
earn that ranch no and he also wanted
half of the income that she earned
during their marriage what a little [ __ ]
yep the judge has upheld the prenup so
that won't be happening but she will
still be paying the spousal support the
child support but her problem
her properties her income everything
that kelly's been working and you know
she works harder than anyone in the
industry what a little she gets
right and also right so by the way we've
been reporting on all this money she has
to pay him
and we didn't even know he's still
trying to take half of everything she's
right and like all this time she thought
she had a prenup and he was trying to be
like we don't have a prenup and i'm
sorry like okay
i appreciate the effort in um contesting
the prenup but like what's the point in
signing one if you're just going to try
and contest it like of course it was
upheld it's a legal document
it's not like kelly's lawyers just like
slipped up or they lost it yeah no i
totally agree and then also so she found
out this news while she was on set of
the voice and she like was cheering with
the
uh voice co-host but fun fact is that
blake shelton used to be managed by
kelly's ex-husband brandon because he
was a manager before he became a wannabe
rancher
and he actually stopped working with him
i think because like he stood with kelly
he stood with kelly as we all do and
should i think that that was like the
best article i've ever read because
there were so many
it's such a multi-faceted article
because
as most things are it's layered and i
was like really happy for kelly but the
more i read the article the more
interesting factoids popped up like one
that blake shelton used to be managed by
this man two that like everyone on set
including ariana grande was cheering for
kelly clarkson when she got the email
that her prenup was being upheld and the
judge did not agree to his appeal yeah
so this is just a it's celebrations i
wonder
a little more good news at the bottom of
the article the amount that clarkson
will ultimately have to play black stop
black stock a number that is likely to
be far less than the original order will
change once the judge sorts out their
property agreement she'll still likely
have to pay child support which will
cost her fifty thousand dollars per
month but that's for her kids but it
could be less than the 200 000 per month
that we had initially reported got it
got it got it everything's coming up
kelly everything's coming up kelly yeah
that is really great
are you ready for our next story that i
totally forgot about until right now so
i'm just adding it because it's like the
big story of yesterday he
collected me up
oh man you know this must be really hard
for kelly
i'm actually being dead serious right
now
yeah
well obviously like hard for her because
divorce is hard but like if you ever
have known
have heard the song piece by piece by
kelly it's about like how her dad
abandoned her and like how she found a
man who will never abandon her and like
here we are
not only did he leave he's like trying
to take everything you have so i guess
that song's probably painful i will
never leave her like you left me and she
will
never have to wonder her worth because
unlike you i'm gonna put her first and
you know
he'll never walk away he'll never break
her heart what about he'll take care of
things
what about the part he'll never walk
away he'll never ask for money
what about she says he'll never walk
away he'll never ask for money at one
point oh my god you're so [ __ ] right
and he's asking he never rests for money
he takes care of things cause he loves
me
he takes care of nothing he steals your
house and he does ask you for money oh
my god love is blind kelly like
i don't fault you i love you still just
please don't please don't like not
perform that song anymore because it's
like you know it's
false you know yeah it's been
invalidated i agree um but just a
reminder that kelly makes a million and
a half dollars a month
so that's pretty sweet
i'm just thinking of all the things i
would do with a million and a half
dollars a month yeah what's 1.5 times
12.
i think 18 million oh i did that math
um
it's honestly not that much like for
kelly she feels like she'd be doing
better
no seriously because how much you think
her voice salary is like yeah no i'm
sure there's more to it you know and
then she probably should start a line of
dusters she has by the way a line that
wayfair of furniture like oh furniture
no i need kelly clarkson clothes
i like kelly clark kelly clarkson's
caftans she give us a calf tabs around
for her money
yeah
early charlie clarkson's
kimonos
okay
kelly clarkson
[Music]
are you ready for our next story it's
the next story
okay wow i'm being really annoying like
i need to reel it in like the one person
who left a comment one saying she hates
the hangover episodes like he's like now
you're dead he's no longer a fan of
fishing okay sorry no i'm gonna reel it
i'm like let's be cool i mean britney
spears father jamie spears agrees to
step down from conservatorship
the turn of events is a massive win for
the international pop star who has been
placed under a conservatorship for 13
years ever since spears placed his
famous daughter under the court-ordered
arrangement in 2008 when she suffered a
very public breakdown but in the 13
years since she has been fit enough to
perform tour
to perform tour hold las vegas dragon's
residency and earn hundreds of millions
of dollars and now he's finally stepping
down after like years of everyone asking
him to do so so this is a small win
i have one thing to say to jamie spears
get out leave right now
he did
i'll believe it when i see it okay
i also like write a report that this
report like wasn't true
so did i
but like everybody's saying that it's
true tmz variety you know they usually
know what they're talking about yeah no
but then i i did also see like he didn't
actually step down
so what does that mean
i have no [ __ ] clue like they're
gonna just bore us to death with this
yeah that we stop caring yes but we'll
never stop caring hashtag free brittany
i agree
it's not gonna work
jamie spears first of all the fact that
there's a jamie spears in a jamie lynn
spears it's very confusing
jamie spears is like a little raisin
you mean look spice yeah it's like
shriveled up and wrinkly
i
this picture i'm seeing if it must be
old because he looks
fine no that's what he looks like he
honestly looks like a senator
yeah he does like you could literally
put that picture like
like in the new york times and i'd be
like oh look the senator i'm sure the
picture is in the new york times oh my
god you know what i mean the political
section
this is
a political matter yeah yeah
are ready for our next story which is a
little
artifact news
a little
artifact
a slice of charles and diana's 1981
wedding cake sells for over 2
500.
that's so disgusting and i was actually
thinking first of all do they know who
took it
who bought it no who took it home from
the wedding oh i don't know oh wait the
piece was given to moira smith who
worked for queen elizabeth at clarence
house she wrapped the slice in plastic
and stored it in a floral cake tin with
a label on top reading handle with care
prince charles and princess diana's
wedding cake with the date she her
family sold the cake in 2008 to jerry
layton a private collector from leeds
do these people know that like things
rot
well i mean you are when you get married
like you put a slice of wedding cake in
the freezer that's like a tradition and
then you eat it on the one year but like
why not 40 years yeah no there's
something really unsanitary about this
but like it still has like a lot of the
schmaltz and stuff yeah well i was
thinking like what losery ass wedding
guest
snuck this at home in their purse you
know
and if they're losery enough to do that
how would they have gotten invited but
now it makes sense that it was like
from diana or elizabeth you said yeah
from yeah someone who worked for
queen elizabeth
very interesting did you see the field
of dreams
i saw i read about it it was actually
really cool look um
basically you've seen the movie right no
me neither but you know what it's about
a field that has a dream yeah like this
kid like love you know by the way i'm
gonna hatch this but
hatch
this kid like loves baseball or some
[ __ ] in the middle then he like leaves
his house to like you know
think about baseball i don't know and he
goes to his corn field like because he
lives on a farm or some [ __ ] and like
one night he goes out and there's like a
full-blown
mlb size stadium like in his corn field
and it's like this beautiful thing and
he keeps sneaking out and like playing
baseball with his friends or whatever i
don't know that's definitely not how it
goes but i know that there's a field
kevin costner's in it that i heard
and i don't know if the field already
existed like from the movie set
but the yankees played there last night
yeah they had kevin coster throw out the
first pitch and he was like in the um
mc box like with the other you know
voice over broadcasters
and i thought it was such a cute idea
and moment yeah and stunning jackie was
farm chairman like for miles my
understanding of what happened last
night was that
they've been building this new stadium
called like the field of dream stadium
it's probably like in a corn field it is
and it's like modeled off of the movie
and they've been building this for a
while and it finally is built it's so
cool and they had their first game there
last night and then i also read that the
game was like a game for the ages you
know they came back they came back they
won not like a boring right with like no
score so like in the movie
there's like these big tall stacks of
corn
and like these baseball players like
come out of the corn right i read that
too and so they remade it was so cute i
like never saw the movie and i don't
like baseball but i'm like i was gonna
cry i'm like this is so sweet no i never
saw the movie i don't like baseball but
this just sounds like nostalgia well
done yes it was
so
top-tier
elegant yeah that's pretty cool yeah i
thought it was really great that's
really cool and like i need to go to
that stadium and have a photo shoot like
that like a bachelorette girl in a
cornfield you should get stunning where
is it iowa iowa been meaning to go to
des moines for a minute we'll go on tour
well sorry not wool well go on
no no apostrophe w-e-l-l comma we get it
go on tour jackie wants people to know
she's not going yeah i think that was a
little confusing
you know des moines i can't but
but i really want to go like i just buy
a farm and never come home yeah and live
in the house that kelsey lived on when
she was in the bachelor you should do a
stop there on your tour so that way you
can tour the city yeah that's like i
really can't that's what you like to do
for sure
are you ready for our next story which
is some loser on loser crime oh my god
in the biggest way i didn't realize we
were going to be getting some lose round
loser today i don't even know if you've
heard about this crime because it's that
losery
bachelor nation's jeff holm
files a restraining order against robbie
hayes wow
jeff with one f jeff with one f home has
filed a temporary civil harassment
restraining order against robbie hayes
documents filed on august 9th in los
angeles obtained by e news show
according to court records viewed by e
news jeff's request for protection was
granted by a judge who ordered robbie to
stay a hundred yards away from jeff's
home in workplace in the filing jeff
described robbie as an old roommate who
used to live at his la area home it's
unclear from documents when their
friendship soured and robbie moved out
but quote at least once a week jeff
states robbie enters his property
without permission and becomes hostile
jeff wrote in the follow in the filing i
do not feel safe around him he threatens
me and still hasn't stopped to this day
he claims he has belongings there and
that's why he enters but he is not on
the lease and is making me fearful
honestly talk about a fall from grace
and like i thought it was crazy when
like robbie made it to jojo's top three
but like he was like the bell of the
ball you know like everyone he was on
paradise he was so funny social media
manager
and like now he's like going to jail
i don't think he's going to jail
i think it's just like jeff holmes like
really annoyed by him and he keeps like
showing up i don't know what he might
have left at the house and
jeff got a restraining order like yeah
this is just like really
yeah because they were like probably
running around town they were remembered
yeah starting their own company like
yeah like doing like influencer
losery things yeah and now this is how
that ended for them well that's just
goes to show you it never ends well when
you're a loser no no it really and don't
forget that robbie was on the siesta key
like being extremely illusory and
throwing throwing phones into the lake
and lying about it yet literally
robbie's is a loser yeah
yeah but he's always been really nice to
me i just want to say that yeah but i
just feel like publicly he's just maybe
i don't know what he is like in his
private life you know but everything
that he does publicly is just always the
wrong move well it seems like in his
private life he's going and harassing
ex-roommates right
yeah
just a really [ __ ] weird story
totally jeff home is also like weird
yeah another fall from
emily maynard could have any man in the
world chose jeff holm
and look weird which was a really weird
and then he was living with robbie hayes
like
it was a really bad call from her
yeah who would you want to see her i
don't remember all of her guys but she
must have not had amazing guys because
she ended up with jeff
i feel like ari lyndike was first from
her season
that would be crazy i love emily maynard
like she's emily maynard must be
protected
[Music]
who were the men
sean lowe was her number three by the
way
by the way i just want to say like i
love sean and catherine together but
emily maynard and sean are actual
perfect matches
but they're they're not they're actually
like too similar yeah
he was her third who was her second i
really feel
like it was ari
no
i feel like maybe it was yeah
bachelorette hold on right runner up
okay run her up
my phone is just a blaze ari wow that's
crazy that is crazy and she chose jeff
well
i bet she doesn't regret that decision
no i'm sure she doesn't regret anything
because she's so
has such a wonderful life such a
wonderful marriage she's a 1 000
children family and she's living the
life that she said that she wanted when
she first showed up on the bachelor
bradwell next season and so that's all
you can like really hope for someone
totally
are you ready for our fizz and final
story already yeah we just cruised
through on this friday because we're
getting you into the weekend as quickly
as we can what story is it
it's the final story
[Music]
[Music]
okay it's little real houses beverly
hills production news twofold first
erica jane feels bravo pulled a fast one
with garcelle spat so there's some
behind the scenes by the way there was
some choppy editing in that scene
there's some behind the scenes tea there
behind the scenes or behind the scenes
behind the scenes because unfortunately
they're not steams
erica jane's upset and anger toward
garcelle on wednesday's episode of the
real housewives was actually directed at
production an insider exclusively told
page six while jane accused well sorry
while erica accused garcelle of
betraying her friendship by revealing
that tom still called her amid their
divorce in a scene with all the cast
mates page six is told that erica felt
she was actually betrayed by producers
on the network quote they cut it and
pasted it in a way to make it look like
she was upset but she was actually mad
that garcelle was told to say three
times and she took the bait they had
three different conversations about the
same subject the insider added what they
didn't show is that erica and crystal
had a private conversation where no
cameras were on and producers heard it
via their mics
when they got in the car producers said
they overheard it and asked crystal to
ask erica on camera bravo didn't want to
do the fourth wall they pulled a fast
one they're told that garcelle was
actually never part of the conversation
that crystal and erica had and that's
why footage of the women walking with
their backstage camera was shown with
the voiceover from the hot mic so i was
thinking
that
that piece of information was very juicy
why are we getting it as like a toss
away when they're walking back from the
hike and the fact that we saw their
backs was weird yes so but then a
separate source is saying no erica's
reaction to garcelle was genuine but
then lisa arena posted on thursday night
an instagram story that that said dang
it i wish they had shown the screaming
fight between the producer and erica
last night on the show in la quinta now
that would have been epic tv too bad
bravo bravo [ __ ] bravo i'll get in
trouble for this in five four three two
one shut up elise arena okay bravo
rubber [ __ ] bravo you cannot say that
you can't say that denise made that
famous not you yeah agreed
but it does answer a little bit of
some of the confusion as to why erica's
reaction was so big and knowing that
probably it wasn't all directed at
garcelle and
there was just producer intrusion
because it was really a messy situation
i also read an article yesterday from
all about rht but i didn't see it
anywhere else that
beverly hills producers are going to be
giving unaired footage from all of
erica's seasons
to the courts in order to piece together
more of the girardi case stuff i think
it's mostly stuff from like her first
season about like their lifestyle and
things like that and just things that
they said back then to see if like
because they think that that money that
she was spending in the first season
like came from the lion there because
unclear if that's true because i only
saw it in one place
all about tea all about the tea already
you know it yeah those are the blogs
they're always referring to right but i
thought that was an interesting factoid
but also it's really interesting at a
certain point
those things might be court ordered for
bravo to have to give over anyway but i
think right now they're just
um they're cooperating without being
subpoenaed or anything and
so that's interesting well with this car
cell thing i just think it's very clear
that it was choppy choppy editing like i
have
even before this story the whole thing
made no sense yeah like who heard what
what was that
yeah it made a little bit of sense just
that like she said it to them walking
back to the car and then
garcelle missed the part where she said
don't mention it to anyone else right
but i guess she said it to crystal solo
and then producers told garcelle about
it
and garcelle
did what they asked well i kind of
respect crystal a lot for not taking the
bait even as like a first-time housewife
you pretty much just like
do what you're told yeah um
that's very cool but but crystal was the
only one who had the information plus
the knowledge of please don't repeat
this like i didn't say this on camera
you know what i mean whereas garcelle
just heard that oh erica said this to
crystal let's say to us too i do feel
like it's interesting how erica opened
up to crystal about that when they don't
even know each other yeah and sometimes
when you just you know
you turn on the faucet
it all comes out you know it's hard to
like stop the the sharing yeah so i feel
like erica either shares or doesn't
share yes
you know what i have to say she's been
very um
i think a lot of women regardless i know
she needs the money but a lot of women
wouldn't have been able to like face
this season like i'm like adrian malouf
could even show up to the reunion when
she got divorced but erica needs the
money i know and like this is the but it
must be the role of a lifetime and if
she's smart about it which she is a
smart person like she could use it to
her advantage having
being able to get her side out there
it's actually like a win-win for her
it's hard work and it's probably really
painful for her but she can get more out
of it than if she just hides and acts
guilty yeah
i just don't have a good feeling about
it no me neither
um so those are the past five stories
feel so you needed to know them and we
sort of already talked about love island
but i would just want to reiterate that
if you're wondering who to vote for i
would say vote for jeremy and bailey
voting is only open for like 30 minutes
no it's open again one more time okay i
have to [ __ ] register i couldn't get
it
okay it's opening in one more time like
after tonight's episode or something and
then the finale is on sunday yeah i
think so
i'm just really enjoying watching the
castmates who are at home like they're
being so active on social media yeah and
i'm living for it yeah no it's true
so are you gonna vote for jeremy and
bailey
i have to watch but
either them or charlie and elena okay
or olivia and corey kidding no that
can't be kidding
i love charlie and elena just like
visually i think they're the
best-looking couple yeah
they are really cute i can't believe
trina went home after all she's [ __ ]
been oh my god claudia was disgusting
like and who was kind of like leading
the group well so it wasn't like that
each couple got to vote
so the couples broke off they all had
conversations
and
we kill
williams
voted them out
elena and charlie voted them out
olivia and corey voted them out [ __ ]
and they were already [ __ ] by that
point and then jeremy and bailey voted
them out too
the only other couple who got one vote
which was from trina and andre was
charlie and alana yeah so it's like i
understand why charlie and lana voted
for them because they were the two
weakest links fine but
i can't deal with these cast members
when they vote out their best friends
and then they're so emotional that these
people are going home so like
kira and olivia were so upset that trina
was going home and said you guys could
have not sent her home you know
also like did anyone want to step up and
vote off will and kira thank you you
know
literally the most problematic couple
since day one you know also they need to
go home and figure their [ __ ] out they
really shouldn't be here a minute longer
because until kara sees that footage she
has no idea what to do with her
relationship and until she knows what
it's like in the real world with him
like he like he's not using her for the
money or the show the show isn't
bringing them closer anymore like
they're just waiting till they can go
home so go home so go home and figure it
out go to sleep um
and then
olivia and corey was a big
disappointment like why are you going to
vote off your friend when you could
easily vote off charlie and elena why
i literally despise olivia and corey
it's crazy actually not even corey
no like it's just so fraudulent it's so
fraudulent yeah and like she's a
different person from the first episode
and it's just like an amalgamation of
all the other girls
yes yeah yes yeah
who is the real olivia i don't know and
i don't want to know no me neither i've
seen enough
also i caught up on white lotus last
night oh i i'm all caught up okay so um
it's still like really weird so but
things happened i guess
the main thing is like the robbery yes
which is actually crazy which was really
crazy and i don't know where like where
we go from here and if he's right
because the daughter knows that it was
her friend like who
she i think she has a suspicion but i
don't think she knows that i think she
does you think she knows that she sent
him no not like all the details but she
knows that this girl was involved yeah
yeah i think so too but i think until
she gets like the facts and also would
she even
snitch
right because she's such a bad daughter
i cannot stand her she's probably my
least favorite character on the show no
hands [ __ ] down my least favorite is
rachel oh the honeymoon girl i cannot
stand her so annoying but also you know
what like her husband's a dick but my
god she's such a nitpicker like she just
doesn't stop fighting like
it's she's just
miserable and her husband is a dick but
like at least like he's like i'm sorry i
was on his side about the room he paid
for a nicer room
and he didn't get it and the manager
then sent him on that treacherous
journey on the boat like
i'm sorry this man has been wronged by
the hotel
i can't deal with the manager like he
has a disgruntled client
he's so self-destructive no he's so
self-destructed like literally someone
asks him for something that he doesn't
want to do so he has to like break his
sobriety and take a drink no like he's
so destructive i cannot no it's and he's
so like put in the beginning he's like
so put together his job it's just it's
so much but he said the thing that broke
him was seeing that woman go into labor
which was such a crazy crazy thing that
happened but he wasn't even like
emotional about it he like i don't even
think that broke him no i know
um oh but the scene where he was in a k
hole like eating ass and then the guy
from
from the pineapple suite
[Laughter]
from the trade winds like comes it's
actually historical
he's in the palm room yeah oh my and
when shannon showed up i was like living
for it the palm room was so toasty also
like their next room did not have a
water view like no i know and like it
was like bigger and on the ground and
sure they had their plunge pool but like
their original room was nicer that's
always what happened always
um what else and then the this lady who
works at the spa like you just really
want her to win
such a nice lady and it's just so
annoying that jennifer cool is just like
so distracted by like this guy she's
just like so crazy i know it's just
like for the last few days she's been
like so annoying towards
melinda
belinda belinda and
now it's like she has her new mans and
she's just like so useless yeah i kind
of like hate everyone that's the thing
okay i hate most of them um like i said
i i think the younger brother is having
some character development yeah and like
now he's going out with the rowers and
like he's interested in nature and he's
like doesn't have his phone all day
because he was like out with throwing
the road like he's he's changing i agree
i i do i i do tolerate him but like
honestly i despise
everyone
okay i i'm trying to see the good
the good in it i pretty much despise
everyone too but it does make me want to
go on vacation
yeah but like the fact that they keep
going to the same breakfast in the same
dinner like it's a cruise ship like
totally this is the nicest restaurant
resort in hawaii like can't you go with
two restaurants i guess they're like
technically in a covered bubble but like
aren't there restaurants
you know
i also did like the daughter's friend
until she put
kai in that really bad spot
who's kai i think that's his name the
guy who robbed oh my god she like forced
him and i know her intentions were good
but like
his life could be ruined yeah but i
liked her before that me too but she her
heart's in the right place but she's
just like a
immature like and like i like that she
like has like the four one one on her
friend you know and he's like same
because that friend is so [ __ ] so
conniving when that friend went over to
that takai to like try and [ __ ] him yeah
and then she found out that girl's such
a little snake such a little snake i
really i like connie britton too in the
show
and like i don't mind her she's like
very annoying
i mean i'm trying to everyone everyone
is so annoying everyone is so annoying
so like the dad was really annoying in
the beginning
yeah with like like his mid-life crisis
no and he's still annoying when he found
out his dad died of aids that was the
beginning
like i'm saying like now where he was at
the beginning
i know and he's like telling his son
about the affair and he's trying to be
more like engaged i'm just like i'm
still not understanding like why we're
watching the show but like also don't
some people go on vacation and like are
good fun people where are those people
yeah like where's like the there's the
bachelorette party totally
actually they'd probably be the worst to
watch no where's like the
the mom's getting away you know yeah
molly shannon and her friends molly
shannon was hysterical yeah can you
imagine
like your mother-in-law coming on your
honeymoon i love my mother-in-law but
like no no but
like i don't know there's just so much
to do on like at the resort and like no
one rachel just keeps sitting around
like reading her um elena ferrante book
it is really interesting to see the
books the books that what they have each
character reading i'm sure there was
like a lot of thought that went into it
uh the book that rachel's reading is
actually a series that dana really liked
um and it was turned into a tv series on
hbo
um but then like the husband is reading
like blank which i think is like a a
pretty cliche
beach like vacation read got it and then
the girls were reading like freud and
like that was a little stupid yeah like
where who's reading evelyn hugo you know
what i just want to say like
that girl the the daughter the blonde
daughter
like that type of girl
she doesn't read freud like she's a
[ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] don't read freud no but i don't
think she i don't think they were
reading it i think they just like were
wanting to be seen reading it you know i
and i think that's what when the husband
was like flirting with them oh i thought
he was just being an ass no i i feel
like because each day they came down
with like a new philosophical book i
think they just like want to
look more interesting than they are
that's interesting you know also that is
the sort of books that are assigned in
college so like they probably like put
them in there but like i don't think
they're seriously they're like
contemplating
you know a freud freudian yeah and
between the conversations they have with
each other like it's clearly not
that deep them doing asmr and like that
was fun k whole
whatever that is that looked like the
worst experience i actually hate
watching television television shows
where people do drugs and like it goes
badly it gives me the worst anxiety yeah
and there's like of every show there's
an episode like that like and it it
really [ __ ] me up i do not like
watching shows like that no one every
episode is happening with armond like
oh my god totally even though he's not
having like a bad trip no but it's like
he keeps being like just found out or
like he's waking up like hung over on
his couch and like to get back to work
i'm like doesn't your head hurt i was
thinking the same thing like when you
woke up in his car yeah he woke up on
his couch one time and it's like clear
off all the drugs like yeah ow
totally
um
so the finale is this weekend finale's
on sunday so we will recap that on
monday we have a big tv recap on monday
and like who died and how did they die
yeah all we know is that the guy who
didn't die is rachel's husband because
he in the beginning of the show was at
the airport said my wife
no they said he's not with his wife he's
not with his wife and they said didn't
someone die there and then he's like
about i thought he said that's my my
wife no no he didn't no we don't know
who does who do you think it is he just
said like his wife isn't with him
because then we also say she might leave
him 100 so anyone could be and i keep
looking like who
is in the most trouble and i'm like well
i could see this person dying and i
could see this i feel like it's going to
be the sun he's like getting on boats
with random strangers you think no i i
just assumed it was going to be rachel
but now let me think
let's make a guess
i don't know
like jennifer coolidge is very
vulnerable i could see her being killed
easily they're like falling off the boat
yeah
right
i don't know
wow okay something to think about yeah
make it interesting
um so that's our show that's our show
that's that on that hope everyone has an
amazing weekend we'll be back on monday
and thank you for watching the morning
toast millennium morning show where we
hit you with the best live stories every
day make sure to follow us on instagram
subscribe to us on youtube you can
follow my personal jack yasha you can
then see bruce birthday party on sunday
and that's all she wrote we will see you
on monday society
season two the emoji for today is gonna
be the puppy that looks like brew in
honor of his birthday
the first puppy on the animals page bye